[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we sit
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life
hi I'm Danny's I'm joined by my co-host
dr. Greg Sandler today we're talking
about the social contract today and what
we're talking about here is a little bit
different than most of the shows that
we've done it's a little bit more like
the last episode where we're talking
about topical issues of the day and
they're they're not just sort of trivial
things they're very momentous dan and I
have been observing what's been going on
in Milwaukee and I think everyone's
seeing what's going on not just
nationwide but worldwide particularly in
terms of the black lives matter movement
and protests and policing and so one of
the things that we touched on last
episode and said we might think about a
bit more as this notion of the social
contract and so we started kicking this
idea around and we have quite a lot to
go into I think and you know so I mean
what's what's your take on this like
right from the start so that we're
having a breakdown in our social
contract and you know we might need to
kind of define that social contract as a
term or a you know a idea and it's this
idea that there is a certain like
expectations given between the populace
and the government between the govern
and the government what are the reasons
for this what are the expectations that
are given and what are the divisions of
powers between those two groups yeah and
you know sometimes when we have that
expression that a lot of people use
today we live in a society we're
expressing something that's not exactly
the same as this notion of the social
contract but it's very closely related
there's norms that govern you and govern
me and we're all supposed to follow
these norms and we usually point this
out when somebody is is violating the
these norms right so it becomes an issue
and then you know whenever there's some
sort of conflict about whether a rule or
a norm or expectation is legitimate or
has been broken and people don't agree
about that we have to have some way of
adjudicating it otherwise it just turns
into people going back and forth like
when we were kids and I would say yes
and you would say no or right wrong or
whatever it's going to be and then
sooner or later we're going to come to
blows if we can't address these things
before they turn into just pure
aggression all right all right buried
upon set of rules a you know maybe a
third party arbitrator of the situation
at hand otherwise you know it could
easily devolve into negative ends of
physical violence yeah you know it's
interesting we're gonna talk a bit about
classic social contract theory and one
of the things that you see in almost
every one of those early modern
political theorists because it must have
been a big problem at the time was that
when there's a controversy you can't
make one of the one of the sides or one
of the members of the controversy the
judge over the controversy you actually
do need to have something else maybe
it's a set of laws that everyone can it
can get behind maybe it's an impartial
judge maybe it's a partial judge but
somebody who's actually at least removed
from the situation maybe it's what they
called the sovereign or the magistrate
but you got it you can't you can't just
let one side get to decide how the
conflict is going to be resolved because
it's gonna even if it's a good person
there's the the the early thinker the
early modern thinkers thought that's
gonna corrupt a person so if I'm having
a dispute with you I don't know about
you know airtime or something right
you're like yeah you only let me talk
for 20 minutes during the thing and you
talk for 40 minutes and I'm like well
let me tally it up let me let me decide
what's fair you're gonna still end up
with just 20 minutes or maybe I give you
even less may give you
I'll show that guy shut him down and
shut him up you know and so we need we
need something to get us out of that
that sort of situation and it's also
built right into the definition there it
is a contract and it you know you have
to it's like a conversation it's an
agreement between you know two or more
groups or peoples and if they're not
there then you're just you know
asserting authority over someone and
it's no longer a contract yeah and now
we should probably specify that you're
not going to be able to like go to the
Hall of Records and find the social
contract anywhere right it's not that
sort of sort of contract it's something
that's supposed to be more foundational
and often this is where a lot of people
in ordinary discussions and parlance
often get into arguments with each other
and they don't necessarily need to say
the word social contract it could be
just like people sitting at a bar and
and somebody is like hey you didn't
order a round of drinks and I paid for
your round of drinks and then the person
is like well I mean we didn't make any
explicit agreement you know you can you
can buy me whatever you want it's nice
of you to be generous and then the first
person will be like hey that's not okay
there's and they might talk about a
social contract probably not right
they're gonna say other things like
that's not fair or infraction or yeah if
I do this you ought to do that as well
but there's that the basic idea there is
that there's the social contract that
they're supposed to be following and
that's a fairly trivial thing you know
who they're I'd drinks but but it can
extend all sorts of other things as well
I I had a real quick interesting story
to belabor that point is last birthday I
had on I was at a bar for some karaoke
and one of the people that came along
was a gentleman that I just met recently
but he was from India and so we go to
the bar together and he's like you know
on he's expecting me to buy his drinks
and I'm like it's my birthday
I think he thought because like I had
invited him out that was like at least
the first drink that I was going to buy
for him
it might have been his social
expectation and my expectation was the
opposite for that particular situation
well you know there are other cultures
where if it's your birthday you're
expected to buy drinks or food for other
people as well but I don't think I don't
know that India is and I think Germany
is one of those places because I
remember a German friend now maybe she
maybe was making up stories or something
and she was like you know on our
birthdays we try to avoid going out
because we have to pay for everybody
else but I mean you know and that's
that's actually it's a great story
because what it illustrates is that
there the norm itself the the content of
it can change from culture to culture a
situation a situation but the basic
expectation is the same there's supposed
to be some sort of reciprocity there or
given these sorts of conditions you're
supposed to follow through on what
you're supposed to do right so I mean we
have we have basic sort of social
contract involved in all the commerce
that we do if I go into a store and I
you know now normally I would just run
my credit card but let's say I'm paying
cash I give the person a $20 bill I
probably expect some change back you
know right now in other places maybe
there's you know maybe that's not the
expectation and then the social contract
would be you know maintained by my
saying keep the change because that's
what everybody does and so there's
there's a normativity involved in the
social contract and what we're talking
about today is less about how everything
goes great and you know swimmingly or
smoothly or anything like that and we're
saying there's a breakdown sometimes no
well there's there there's many
breakdowns and though many of those
breakdowns get kind of you know they get
remedied or addressed and not always
perfectly there's always some freeriders
that we have to deal with but for the
most part you know people they do things
that we view is breaking the social
contract and then they get sanctioned in
some way what what Jeremy Bentham called
the moral or social sanction you know
people saying hey I want to I don't
wanna hang out with you
you're a jerk or you really ought to go
fix that or you know people doing those
sorts of things rather than what he
called the political sanction where
somebody who's authorized like uses
force on you or imposes a fine or
something along those lines there's also
I should point out to Bentham talks
about the physical sanction there's some
things that if you do them you end up
feeling pain for some reason so there's
some things that are so stupid to do
some violations that you you know you
shouldn't do like you break into
somebody's house and you you get you
know your bellies stuck on the glass as
you're crawling through the window
physical sanction for the wrong act that
you did and maybe next time around you
won't do it you know but if everyone
comes along and and you know says look
at that idiot over there stuck on the
glass well that's the moral sanction and
then you know once the cops come and
take you away in the judge sentences you
political sanction and for Bentham these
all kind of kind of work together
ideally although you know the British
law system of his time was really
baroque and screwed up that's part of
why he wrote the stuff that he did but
comes up broke broke the pun right I
couldn't and so this idea of a breakdown
of social contract there was a video
that happened recently that you wanted
to talk about that with from Kimberly
Jonz
yeah and this is very moving ice I think
a lot of people saw the last two minutes
of it and that's what I saw first where
she was talking explicitly about social
contract so when I saw that I was like
well we have to bring this up during
during our show because it illustrates
what's happening right now and the way a
lot of people feel so it's a six minute
video and we'll put a link to it she
first talks about some of the criticisms
that are being made of the protests so
she's taking a strategy very similar to
like Martin Luther King's letter from a
Birmingham jail where she says our
critics are saying this let me address
that first and to the the criticisms are
the
protesters should not be rioting or
looting and tearing up their own
communities and we hear this every time
that there's something like this going
on and then another criticism of the
protest was that instead of engaging in
any sort of protest or violent action
they should be voting with their
pocketbooks they should be engaging in
in boycotts and blackouts and doing
economic actions and she said well that
works great when you've actually got a
lot of economic clout to bring to bear
and then she says let me talk about the
the protest and she says we can break
them down into three groups of people
and I think she's correct about this
there's the protesters who are the the
vast majority and they're upset and
they're they're quite often angry and
some of them could do you know some
violence at some time but they're not
generally engaging in that and and these
protests that we've been seeing over the
last two weeks it's really remarkable
how much restraint has been shown by
protesters then we actually have rioters
and she says you know some of them are
people who are anarchists and are coming
in and stirring up stuff because they
they've got some ideological conviction
that force is the way to go
and then there's looters and she says
those people are just there to do that
looting and you're always gonna have
some of that and we've seen that happen
here in Milwaukee right and she says
what's really important is not that we
focus on the what of the looters but the
why why why are people doing this some
of them maybe get a kick out of breaking
windows and stealing stuff but you know
I think she's right in saying that many
of them are doing it because they they
see a nation of affluence that they're
locked out from and some of them are in
genuine needs she talks about people who
are so food insecure that they're gonna
break in and take food and that and that
does happen and then she talks about
this metaphor of a game which is you
know again quite quite moving a game
that's rigged from the start against
African Americans but she could be
talking about
all sorts of other racial minorities she
could be talking about women she could
be talking about transgendered people in
in the present there's all sorts of
applications of this so you've a game
that's rigged at the start and then
people work really hard to make it even
though the rules of the game are against
them even though they're not really
getting equal protection or equal
opportunities and then it when they make
it somebody else comes along to knock
them down so to think about the Tulsa
riots you know a prime example or 1919 I
believe I think so yeah
and and those were duplicated not on
that that exact scale but you know all
over the nation for years and years and
years to come you know and you know I
think we should like talk just a little
bit about the Tulsa riot or the Berlin
Wall Street yeah yeah yeah so it is a
hundred years ago and there was a very
affluent community in Tulsa Oklahoma on
call referred to as black Wall Street on
and lots of middle-class lots of black
owned shops you know black owned
theaters and you know a whole thriving
black community and there was one moment
that allow them to the the white
populace that were upset that there were
some black people that were you know
that succeed him yeah yeah I believe
there's a quote about like on he this
guy has a piano in his four-year and I
don't have a piano my barrier why should
the black man have a piano and so then
they they they burned and literally flew
airplanes and bombed this portion of the
city and hundreds were murdered yeah it
was terrorism
on an incredible scale here in in the
United States and and you know to make
things worse the the the riots ended up
getting blamed on the black community as
if they provoked it you know and and we
you know again we can think of many
situations like that what's what's
happening in a case like that
it's what Kimberly Jonz is talking about
as the game is already rigged they
succeed despite the rigging
somebody else comes to knock them down
afterwards so the rules of the game
change even after that and so she says
the game keeps getting rerigged against
African Americans and then there's a
passage where she says well why are
people burning down the neighborhood and
she says it's it's because it's not our
neighborhood we don't actually own
anything and I think that's a really
central concept it's not just about
ownership in terms of property its
ownership in terms of buy-in its
ownership in terms of feeling like you
belong and are part of a community and
will be protected by the same norms as
other people have then she brings up
Trevor Noah who brought it you know who
brought up the idea of social contract
on his show and he was using the example
of stealing and this is a very very
basic concept you find it running in
almost every ethical code keep your
hands off of other people's stuff and he
says you know when the social contract
is violated the authority comes in to
fix the situation and then she says but
the situation is killing us and so the
social contract is broken and that's
that's where I think we have to start in
in thinking about the social contract if
the social contract is indeed broken or
if it never really was what it was
supposed to be then it's a legitimate
question why should she or anybody else
who's not being protected by the social
contract follow the social contract and
she puts it in terms of why should she
care if the Football Hall of Fame gets
burned down it's not her Football Hall
of Fame and she can't even say that it's
it's our Football Hall of Fame you know
and I think that this is this is a very
legitimate question to raise have
african-americans and we can tie it we
can broaden this all sorts of other
people we can talk in terms of class as
well have people been shut out of the
social contract so in order to answer
this of course I think we have to talk
about what the social contract is yeah
we touched on like the basic idea of it
beforehand and so it's kind of like it's
the thing that we're given at birth for
the most part
you know none of us were the ones that
like set up a country and there are a
few people think they are but but but
we're born into it and we for the most
part we don't ever question the merits
of that contract that we're born into
you know only through experience if it
doesn't work for us then do we start to
do that and and for those people who the
social contract is working for they have
no reason to upend the status quo you
know and then when someone dares to say
that the system is no good
many will defend that system
unthinkingly without looking at the
merits of the argument being put forth
and say kind of a society by way of a
sports affiliation now what do you mean
by that like sort of like a routing for
your team or yeah like you know without
unthinkingly and it's like that this is
the way it is and and this is good
because it was the thing that we all
have okay I could I can see that because
it's if somebody were to say well I'm
I'm you know I grew up here in Wisconsin
but for once I actually want to like
think through my sports team affiliation
which of the NFL team should I be
supporting and a lot of people say that
I should support the Packers because I'm
from here but you know I should give
each of them a look I'd say oh that's a
very unusual person I I don't know that
that's how we decide our sports
allegiances and so you're saying that
this that the social contract that we're
inhabiting and guiding our actions by is
something usually like that yeah just
that we're given to it and then unless
we accept it and we bring it in to us as
part of our person just because that is
the way that we were the water that we
were swimming in when we you know we're
born so I don't think that's the way it
is yes so it's almost like we drink some
of the water and it becomes part of the
the fabric of our our body that all
right it's not just that the waters
external
to us I mean classic social contract
theory they tended to talk about it in a
very artificial way where like people
got together at some time and they
didn't have a government and they all
like came to an agreement and said these
are the basic norms that we ought to be
following and then who's gonna be who's
actually gonna be in charge of this
who's gonna administer these norms oh
we'll pick that guy over there and give
him a couple assistants to work with and
it never was a philosopher's way of
thinking probably was nothing like that
there was like some guy and he was like
the big guy and he like started doing
things and over time certain things were
better than other things and and then
certain ways of doing things just kind
of grew out of that and he's this kind
of like the philosophers are like oh
well kind of looking back at what we are
given and saying like well if someone
was to do this from the blank slate how
would they have done that yeah I mean I
don't know that Hobbes and Locke really
thought that anybody ever did have one
of those sort of get-togethers but they
certainly thought that you could do that
in the future and you know we do so we
do stuff kinda like that at certain
times when we're dealing with creating
new institutions or conflicts if we if
we're doing an irrational way rather
than just letting somebody make the
choice because they own everything or
you know because we're all too lazy to
to be in on the designing process that's
another thing as well but yeah I like
the idea of internalizing it that you
are bringing up I think that's that's
dead-on I think that a lot of people
view the social contract is something
that we can call on with other people
precisely because we think that they
like us have internalized it and that's
part of what goes into being like a good
citizen or an upstanding person or a
decent human being yeah I think of like
you know slavery in our country and for
those states that practice it it was
like that's just the way things were and
that you know it made sense that
these people were I considered lesser
and thus totally deserved to be property
which is a horrid statement but if you
are born into it and everyone says that
you know says this and it becomes really
difficult for you to move against that
particular position you know and that's
interesting because I think they were
like a lot of gradations one of the
reasons I think why you know when you
look at the literature of the time that
the the worries about being sold further
down south was that the further south
that you went the more oppressive the
the slave regime was and the less I mean
people could still say well this is this
is BS you know this this is unfair
because there were some people saying
that even in the deepest of the south
but you'd have to really work to find
them compared to you know the the areas
that were more on the border you could
say mm hmm so this once you have people
that are starting to push against the
status quo this is a time to reflect and
and is it's a wake-up call to say like
oh you might need to reassess the
preconceptions you're that you are we're
given and maybe this thing isn't working
and if you just dismiss it outright then
I don't think you're being like honest
about the position that you're taking
you're just taking that I guess on faith
okay yeah that that makes sense so what
do you think we can take from classic
social contract theory that helps to
make sense out of the condition that
we're in now in in late modernity here
in the United States here in Milwaukee
seeing some people definitely being
treated for four generations in ways
that were unfair and then on top of that
you know often being penalized for even
pointing out the the unfairness of it do
you think there's anything to these
these you know like Hobbes and Locke and
Rousseau and
these uh yeah and there's there's it
depends on again of these three that
we're talking about Hobbs Lochner so it
all stems at least to a certain extent
from this idea of a state of nature the
state of nature and you know this idea
of what we were like as human beings on
before any sort of like government or
organization between the people and and
the reason that is very important is
because depending on your idea of the
state of nature it'd be it like like
warlike and barbarous or like
potentially more idyllic or maybe moral
on that it will definitely change the
way in which you respond to what needs
the social contract have and in direct
arts to the question at hand you know
specifically like I'm walking or so do
advocate for you know there should be
some way to overthrow this social
contract if it is not being the is not
actually beneficial to the people itself
yeah and both of them in talking about
that it's not the contract per se is
like a set of norms that they usually
have a problem with it's the person
who's in charge of enforcing it who is
either being lazy or selfish or partial
or malicious or you know doing it doing
something that they're not supposed to
do and they they usually is the word
like Locke talks about the executive
Rousseau talks about the magistrate and
so you know one of the things that you
see social contract theory always
focusing on is why should the people who
are having authority used on them why
should they go along with it and and in
some cases Locke would say they can push
you so far and then after that you
revolt and that's that's a okay I mean
that was the justification for the
American
revolution Russo ends up being used by
the the French to talk about their own
revolution so that's that's an important
part of it you know do you think it
boils down to conception of well you
know human beings can be viewed as
basically good or basically bad or is
that is that oversimplifying this well
it's a little oversimplifying but like
that's the idea that humans are
basically bad as kind of the idea of
Hobbes that's you know was human nature
is like warlike and a human life is
suffering and short well he says that
outside of the bounds of society human
life is nasty brutish and short
and the idea is well that's why you need
a very powerful Authority and Hobbes is
really somebody good to bring up here so
he's very worried about falling into a
state of nature and there's a couple
different ways in which this gets
construed it could be like some
legendary state where we're all like
hitting each other with clubs of fur you
know whatever it is that we've got or it
could be like you know a society
breaking down an actual society because
of people not being able to get along
and not not just motivated by
competition or you know not liking each
other but they can't agree on moral
norms and how things ought to be judged
so so society itself breaks down and he
saw that happen with the English Civil
War which is incredibly bloody and
violent he was sitting it out in Paris
at the time I've got to know the young
young king who later brought you know
when they took over and Hobbes was
actually one of his favorites for a
while and Hobbes thinks that you know
here's and here's where it's very
applicable you have to have a really
powerful what he called sovereign who
has the power of life and death over all
of us and who not only gets to make the
rules but who cannot be questioned er
traitor between these warring factions
you can't even work for Hobbs you can't
even allow there to really be factions
you needed you need to defang them and
disarm them nobody can be stronger than
the sovereign if you allow private
armies because that was a big problem
you know mowing the aristocracy they'd
have actually you have these private
armies you're gonna your sooner or later
you're gonna be in trouble
and so Hobbs would say whoever happens
to be in charge it's always better to
let them be in charge than to risk
everything falling apart and so I think
a lot of people who are making
justifications for you know a lot of
excessive police force right now are
pretty Hobbesian they they view the
police as the thin blue line against the
chaos and barbarism and anarchy that
would be happening if we don't support
them and I think this um
you know sometimes emboldened the police
themselves to view themselves as the
magistrate who is who gets to impose
their will on everybody else and who
cannot be questioned and that that's
what we see in these protests right a
lot of the police aggression and
brutality has been against people
questioning the police saying right what
are you doing over there
you know why are you shooting tear gas
at us this isn't right and then the
police come in and start just you know I
mean the things that we've been seeing
on video over the last week are very
eye-opening the response to police
brutality with police brutality or the
the response of the protests against
police brutality with police brutality
yeah and I think that that that is quite
Hobbesian and and it's an attempt to try
to impose let's call it a warped social
contract a social contract that doesn't
actually serve the people under it a
Hobbesian social contract isn't a very
good social contract it's you know to go
back to last week this distinction
between positive and negative peace yeah
what explain that a bit for those who
haven't heard so because positive and
negative peace is this idea that where
you can have peace which is just the
lack of violence and a negative peace is
lack of violence due to exerted force
and so you know prisons can be peaceful
because there's a force that will do
great harm to you if you step out of
line
but that doesn't really well translate
into a community and the idea of a
positive peace is that one in which is
you know full of justice that people on
want to be interacting and there's no
want for any sort of violence to be
happening in the first place that people
are all have total buy-in whereas you
know the negative peace is one where you
know people don't have buy-in but they
only don't revolt because of the
repercussions it just doesn't result in
a happy Society or community as a
festering pustule waiting to burst you
know that reminds me too of st.
Augustine in the City of God he talks
about peace is something that all all
human beings actually do desire and seek
and he he brings up you know there's
there's people to bring up
counterexample and he's like well I can
answer this one of this one in this one
we don't have to go too much into that
but he he points out that even those who
go to war really do want peace but they
want peace on third terms they want to
those who want to dominate other people
they want peace they just want a peace
where they're on top and the other
people shut up and do what they say and
so I think that that's part of the idea
that's that's that's informing that
notion of negative peace what else when
use do we need to bring up about these
would you go a little bit into the state
of nature for you know locking or so
away from our hops you an idea that we
were kind of sure moment yeah I mean so
for Locke he says the state of nature is
not a war of all against all it's just
rather unpredictable and he pictured
wrongly the the condition of the Native
Americans here before the coming of
Europeans as being that sort of state
and he he thought that the biggest
problem with the state of nature is that
just without any sort of authority
we're inevitably going to wind up when
we do come into con
like not being able to resolve it fairly
because we don't have any impartial
judge and he also is much more Pro human
well yeah and and yeah human morality
and and also you know he thinks that we
shouldn't just put up with anything from
the executive the Hobbesian sovereign is
a bad ruler from a lock-in perspective
you know Mattei Kawai our right so again
I think is part of the justification of
the American Revolution they're gonna
take away our rights then we should
revolt against them and Locke is often
used by conservatives but I think he
could have quite a radical
interpretation as well and then Rousseau
who has been used a lot by radicals
Russo's kind of a weird one he's he's
sort of all over the map he has a piece
called the social contract but he has
all these other discourses as well and
he thinks that we as human beings and I
think he's entirely right about this we
developed from a state where we don't
have not just government but even any
institutions at all like language
technology and then we developed this
sort of stuff and we move out of what he
calls pure savagery into barbarism where
we do have some sort of norms but
they're not they're not codified in the
way that they are in a civilized society
and he thinks people are happier under
barbarism I don't know that that's
really the case but he makes he makes a
case for it and then he says with
civilization we can develop much more
complex societies but they're also way
more unequal as a matter of fact one of
the discourses is called the discourse
on the origin of inequality among men
and in it he points out that once we
actually have like a social contract in
place and we appoint the people who are
going to be in charge that doesn't mean
that everything goes along swimmingly
after that as a matter of fact there are
these differentials of say well some
people are very very wealthy and and
wealth is not just something that sits
still you can use it to do other things
and and very often the wealthy it wasn't
just Rousseau pick you know talking
about this Machiavelli talks about this
to the rich oppressed the poor it's
almost like a commonplace throughout
social theory from the ancient time all
the way to the modern times and then we
have you know power Authority and then
we have social prestige or social status
and Rousseau notes that if you got one
of these you can probably get the others
so if you have political authority you
can use your position to make yourself
very wealthy this is what we see our
political class doing today it's why
it's why you know people who become
presidents or senators or Congress
people for the most part you know they
may have been able to relate to us when
they first were getting into office
after a while they can't really relate
to the rest of us at all
they're so insulated a really could you
define a Rousseau's idea of barbarism
here it's a state before we actually
have a sort of functional government in
place and what we're relying on is we
could call them de facto authorities who
you know like you think about tribes
before you have a fixed government and
people tribal elders or yeah but also
people sort of you know they have their
culture and they follow the norms but
they take the norms into their own hands
so they they punish people when they're
going to and you could have somebody
who's who's a king or something but
they're not a king in the in the same
sense with having like the whole
bureaucratic administration beneath them
and so you know these kind of fade into
each other he presents it as if there's
like and almost like an on/off switch
like you go from savagery and barbarism
barbarism into the social contract but
it's not quite so simple of course but
he does think that we things get bad
enough we will break the society will
breakdown and the social contract will
be broken and the trouble is as
civilized people we're going to be worse
off than a bunch of savages we would
have been better off becoming savages
because now
kind of spoiled and we'll put together a
new social contract and we'll just have
this cyclical thing where it works for a
little while and then you know the rich
and the powerful take more than their
fair share and they use the social
institutions like say the police to
reinforce their rule against others and
you know then we have another revolt and
and that that's the way he see things
going on and done the French Revolution
was in some respect an attempt to say no
you're wrong or so we can actually have
a just society turned out it wasn't
completely just you know cake cans also
well that's law like heads oh that was
yeah that's prior to but but then I mean
we're a little bit off topic here but
the French Revolution was a bourgeois
revolution it was for the people who
owned and could it could you know use
their property it was not a revolution
that was to the benefit of all human
beings even though they had you know
these the universal ideas and as Mary
Wollstonecraft pointed out in her
vindication of the rights of women it
was all it was it was also not
particularly good for women so the first
iteration was definitely a proponent or
a test case for Rousseau yeah I suppose
you could say so they thought they were
getting out of the Rousseau en de Latour
predicament and they didn't actually do
so but I mean and and this is a good
place I think to bring in something that
we were going to talk about a little bit
later another theorist Charles Mills who
has talked about the racial contract
that and it doesn't just apply to the
United States you can find similar
things you know done in different ways
say in Brazil or in in France or in
other places but what he points out
about America is that we we've been very
attracted to this notion of social
notion of social contract right but our
social contract from the very beginning
was not a it was not a full social
contract instead there was a he thinks a
deeper racial contract that was more
fundamental to Western society as we
started you know
you know evaluating people in terms of
things that had not been markers
beforehand that we're meaningful in
terms of race and the race in this
racial contract again nobody got
together and said let's sign this and
you know work this out it just can't
happen this way it determined who would
count as a person so some people were
were counting fully as people others
were only partially people some were not
considered to be people at all just
animals
you know machinery to be used it could
determine you know in which
circumstances a person would be
considered to be a person and
unfortunately well I mean no matter how
it happens to people this is this is
gonna be bad but it happened along
racial lines
so as these notions of races became more
and more developed it fell here in the
United States on everybody who wasn't
considered white and you know this this
racial contract you could think of it as
sort of a social contract to include
some people and exclude others and
Mill's really wants to stress that
although there have been a lot of
deliberate decisions by people you know
exhibiting racial prejudice or you know
even engaging in terrorism well let's
say through lynchings and things like
that it works even if people stop being
overtly racist because of systematized
racism and this is a controversial topic
I'll say it's a controversial topic in
the sense that some people think that
there isn't systemic racism that there
aren't worse outcomes in terms of health
or education or all sorts of other
measures for say african-americans here
they think about Milwaukee as there are
for the white population in general it's
controversial not because it's
inherently controversial but its
controversial because some people just
don't want to see that it that it it is
the case and so the the what ends up
happening with social contract theory is
that it ends up hiding the true reality
of things which mill
talks about as being a political reality
but we could talk about it also being
social and economic in terms of health
you know like when I have students who
come to my classes and then you know
will will at some point or another
outside of class say you know I'm not
I'm not feeling all that comfortable and
I said well why and it has to do with
with some of the stuff that's being
discussed in class and who's getting to
talk and who's not getting to talk and I
try to make my classes as inclusive as
possible that's that's part of what
Mills is talking about and that might be
seen as kind of trivial you know
compared to policing but but it it all
you know figures in in one way or
another and I think it all kind of
matters so when so you know to go back
to where we started with Kimberly Jonz
talking about the social contract being
broken
maybe the social contract has been
broken for a very very long time you
know this is the inception of our
country basically and in different ways
sometimes it intensifies you know
bringing up the the the riots and the
destruction of black Wall Street that
would be one particular time where it
was like shoved in people's faces this
contract is not your contract you know
and we'll use we'll use terror and
violence to make sure that that's you
know understood and there's there's a
difference also here between you know
the the laws and the books and the
enforcement of those laws and how that
social contractor that you know I guess
this racial contract yeah is as applied
or not applied based on who has the
power and who can enforce those rules
but you know going back to like trying
to finish up the some of the main ideas
in the social contracts is like why do
we need governments and what are the
power splits between the individuals and
governments and so your Hobbes we have
here this idea that we're giving up our
natural lights in exchange for
protection and just save us from this
what's called the state of nature you
know walk is doing some of the same
but also for adding predictability but
we have the the right to change our
government if it's no longer to our
suiting anymore whereas hots like no you
gotta stuck with it yeah doesn't matter
it's better than the state of nature
anything is that in the state of nature
you can spot if we want to think about
like policing let me let's pause on that
for just a second and think about it
like Hobbs versus Locke right do we have
to have the police departments that we
have do we have to have the officers
that we have are we just sort of stuck
with them I think that's kind of a
Hobbesian point of view yeah you need
them because otherwise everything's
gonna break down
whereas Locke would say you know you
cannot just get rid of the bad apples
but also get it rid of the apples that
are halfway spoiled and maybe start
changing the barrels so that you know
the bad apples actually fall out and if
an entire barrel is contaminated get rid
of it and hire some new ones you know so
like within this last decade they found
that the police force in Puerto Rico
like the entire police of for Puerto
Rico were corrupted Boone and they got
rid of everyone Wow and and started from
the ground up or another example this is
Camden New Jersey
they also had a thing and so they they
broke the contract with everyone in the
police department
and they had everyone reapply and so
basically that allowed them to start
from the beginning and hopefully it had
some good first principles in order to
actually result in a better interaction
with this police but then there's also
the whole movement of just like abolish
the police and so like we've loaded up
so much onto the police that might be
much more suited to someone without a
gun that maybe we don't need as many
police in the first place so that
actually leads into something that I
wanted to talk about maybe that can be
understood as part of like reworking the
social contract right because the
question is okay so if we have a lot of
people who rightly think that the social
contract has been broken for them and
remains broken what are alternatives we
can say well it's too good that you feel
that way but we're going to keep on
going
and then that's kind of a stupid way to
proceed I think because then obviously
things are not going to get any better
and it's it's unjust as well it's in
remain to do that so if we want to have
a new social contract what does the
social contract look like I I think that
reforming police departments would be
part of that but also like you're saying
taking defunding them partially taking
some of those those monies and and
putting them into other things I was
astonished to find out that 41% of
Milwaukee's budget goes to the police
force yeah Mary Alice you know
considering how much people like despise
their property taxes yeah and and so how
much is going towards education how much
is going towards health care how much is
going towards the library you know it's
it's it's less and so I'm not saying
that we need to like you know do more
for the library necessarily I think our
libraries are doing pretty good but
Milwaukee Public Schools could
definitely use some of that money Public
Health yeah and and and the public
health could go towards you know social
workers and people coming in to help us
deal with addiction in different ways
and mental illness in different ways
that doesn't require such a massive
policing presence a lot of times the
policing is detrimental to the
individuals is not actually benefitting
them and so like we're coming to this
point where like you know what happens
when we have this breakdown of our
social contract right now where we're
living that experience and so you you
get people that you know either on start
to you know voice their concerns you
know start to protest it starts small
and then it gets larger and then you
know if you're not going to actually
deal with the protesters and saying that
there's something significantly wrong
but yeah riots are going to break out
because people no longer have any buy
into the system this is kind of the
whole idea with you know on MLK and
Malcolm X
yeah yeah and so either you have a group
that still wants to be part of the
American Society or one that says oh we
could take it or leave it we don't care
anymore and you know violence is a
acceptable way to go about that you know
that's a really good point and I think
part of what's been going on for a long
time and being articulated in many
different ways is this idea that an
American society if there's going to be
buy-in to it from those who've been
marginalised oppressed you know in some
cases terrorized American society has to
be different than what it's been in the
past so it's not like saying well you
fit yourself into this category here
that that we've got no the category has
to widen and change and become more
inclusive and if you want to take a
different example you go to the American
Revolution and you know there were there
protests and then there were you know it
take the the Boston Tea Party you know
there you're getting some destructive
things and then the final step is the
overthrow of government if the
government doesn't respond to the you
know the will the people here then
there's going to be another step in
there you know dissolve those political
unions yeah the Boston Tea Party is an
interesting one because I've seen that
used as a counterpoint and I think
rightly so to people who are like all
this property damage and you know
defacing things oh it's all it's so
terrible and you're like I guess you
don't like the revolutionaries done you
know because they thought that like
throwing all this stuff overboard was
was a-ok in those situations
so how do we reconstitute the social
contract what can we do I mean what
provides us with a good model for what a
a better social contract would look like
I could think at least one would be to
bring in John Rawls he's a rather
contemporary philosopher who talks about
specifically in this regard the idea of
a the veil of ignorance in creating so
you I'll step back a moment he has a
process by which he thinks that people
should create a society in which they
are created and they will not know what
position in that they will be taking
within that society once they join it
and so they basically they'll they'll be
born into the society and they could
either be born into their top of the
society they could be born at the very
bottom to decide its ID or any place in
between and this is the idea this veil
of ignorance that you don't know your
position going into it and it fills that
I guess that is one process by which we
can you know think about this and kind
of the abstract yeah and and the idea is
that you wouldn't know like whether you
you would have any sort of handicaps or
where your desires would lie or what
talents you would have or lacks of
talents or any of those sorts of things
now the question is well how would you
set up society and Rawls thinks well if
you're a rational person you would
definitely not pick a society in which
the poor are like screwed all sorts of
different ways because you might be one
of them it would not be rational to do
that and I you know I think this is
pretty good and I use this with my
students quite a bit and have them sort
of like you know reconstruct what what a
decent society would look like Rawls
thinks that if we do this we're going to
come up with two basic rules and I think
these are pretty good I don't know that
I buy his argument entirely but one of
them is that we would have eat you know
equality of opportunity you know
equality of access to all the basic
goods and so it doesn't mean that
everybody has to have exactly the same
thing but you can't like restrict people
from from enjoying them so for example
racial profiling and in policing would
be ruled out you know because it's it's
restricting people from say public
spaces or work justice and exactly and
then the other thing that he says is
that you can have differences but the
difference is like a doctor can be paid
more but it's got to work out positively
for
the most vulnerable for the person whose
worst off and and we don't do that in
our society well too often were like
well it works out great for the doctor
and it works out great for like you know
the people who can afford him but you
know these people over here too bad for
them and that's leaving them out of the
social contract this is the idea of a
maxi min or a maximum minimum so yeah
any amount of inequality must also raise
the floor by which the lowest in society
exactly
enjoyed the benefits of that society and
it also expresses another principle that
Rawls doesn't talk about but so many
traditions have which is solidarity with
those who are vulnerable you know not
making things harder for them and and
this is I think where some of the
legitimacy of the protests that are
happening goes on what we're seeing by
people who were not you know previously
committing themselves to saying black
lives matter is a recognition that for
too long they haven't and that that has
to change and that a social contract
that we would have that's going to take
us further and not just gonna lead to
interminable cohn conflict is going to
have to include that so we like to end
our shows with the idea of a practice
and so for this week we've got a prac
yeah
making your own social contract so maybe
you want to try to use this rauzein idea
of you know a war would make that a
better you know society for yourself try
to think about what is a sit and think
if you were able to start from a blank
slate what is the society that you would
like what everyone else like it
could you make a contract that everyone
could agree to that's that's a great
thought exercise that's also something
you could do with other people too I
mean I mentioned that we do this in the
classroom when I'm teaching John Rawls
but there's nothing that would prevent
people from like sitting down and saying
hey let's you know we're not going to
like do Plato's Republic utopian society
we're actually going to like pretend
that we don't have any idea what we're
gonna be like let's enter into the veil
of ignorance and then think about what
would be fair and we could actually do
this you could start out by saying let's
do this for Milwaukee let's do this for
what you know our public schools would
look like where our hospitals and
clinics would go where we would put more
police presence where we would have less
of it you know I think this would be a
great exercise for people to do you had
another three in mind though as well oh
yeah so you know Thomas Jefferson you
know one of the founding parents of this
country has this idea that you know the
Constitution should be rewritten every
19 years you know should we be held fast
to laws and ideas that were in vogue on
and thought through 250 years ago are
these laws these ideas evergreen or
their significant ways that we would
differ from those people back then and
you know he thought that like that that
probably wouldn't hold and so he thought
that these basic norms of our society
should be have to be reread upon this is
kind of removing that idea the social
contract from something you're just
given to something that you're actively
a participant in that's actually a great
insight that you know when we look at
the social contract as something that's
oh it's just inherent and we got to
stick with it we we don't see that we
have agency and that because of we have
agency we also have responsibility to
try to make it a more equitable and
inclusive contract so now why every 19
years I don't know that the answer to
that do you know I don't it seems kind
of arbitrary maybe that was part of the
idea you know making arbitrary yeah and
so another resource to maybe look at
this a social psychologist by the name
of Nicholas Christakis who's wrote a
book called a blueprint and it's all
about his research with looking at all
sorts of different societies of the
special lots of plant societies cabooses
and communes as well as every single
time a ship has crashed in an island and
the societies that they set up in those
and he's created a thing called the
social sweet in which he says are the
basic things that all societies must
have in them in order to have a
functioning and continuing organization
so we'll put a link to that you want to
lead us out on some final thought then
yeah so from the president john f
kennedy those who make peaceful
revolution impossible will make violent
revolution inevitable
[Music]